hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well running
throughout his work the myth of Sisyphus
Albert Camus is going to articulate a
standpoint having to do with truth
belief and action and commitment that
might seem to go against some of the
thumbnail sketches of existentialism or
to use qaboos preferred term absurdism
that you might find out there so this
comes up very early in the work and
reappears in a number of important
points he says that the subject of this
essay is the relationship between the
absurd and suicide and then he says that
the principle can be established that
for a man who does not cheat what he
believes to be true must determine his
action so that could appear to be sort
of a throwaway line but it's not it's
actually at the heart of cow Moos entire
project quite often people encounter
existentialist or Camus see an absurdist
literature and they say oh the world
doesn't have any meaning it's absurd
it's meaningless I get to do and say
whatever I want because nothing matters
and that's not actually the position
that Camus
takes nowhere in fact many of the other
existentialist figures even those who he
criticizes instead he's saying that
provides us a certain set of starting
conditions and a constant human
condition that we're trapped within but
it's up to us to make meaning or decide
upon meaning and we also have to remain
you could say coherent and consequential
to ourselves in our thinking our willing
our acting our engagement with the world
so let's go back to this notion of not
cheating he says that the the person you
know nutricious ha right in French they
don't cut corners they don't cheat they
don't give themselves exemptions or
anything like that so for the person he
says who believe who does not cheat what
they believe to be true must determine
their action you might say well where's
this must coming from doesn't the absurd
mean that we throw away all logic all
moral connections no it actually doesn't
mean that the absurd is a little bit
more complex as Camus is going to set it
out so what we believe to be true is
going to determine what we do and and
not just what we do in an individual
circumstance what we do in a global
sense how we conduct our lives and
thinking is also a kind of doing isn't
it so it also has to do with what we
think how we think things out what
position we end up articulating on the
absurd and our life within it so he says
it's legitimate to wonder clearly and
without fake false pathos whether a
conclusion of this importance requires
forsaking as rapidly as possible in
incomprehensible condition and then he
says I am speaking of course of men
inclined to be in her
with themselves so he's not saying that
everybody is automatically gonna follow
his line of reasoning he's saying that
if you're confronted with the absurd
which is what I'm talking about in this
essay and exploring at least in some of
its its features and you have this
inclination to be in harmony with
yourself which by the way is part of why
we encounter absurdity then you have to
grant or acknowledge certain things that
are going to follow from the human
confrontation with the absurd
you can't just wish it away you can't
just ignore it
you can't just lose yourself and sort of
a nihilistic pursuit say of mindless
pleasure seeking right no that would be
being in harmony with yourself even if
you're not able to be in harmony with
yourself at least to drive to be in
harmony with yourself a little bit later
on he's going to say that you know
judging something true one must preserve
it one must keep it so if we think that
the absurd is actually the case then if
we're going to be consequent to
ourselves if we're going to follow
through on our logic mercilessly fairly
without cheating then we can't wish the
absurd away
we can't lose ourselves in any leap into
faith or into the irrational or take you
know those things or the absurd itself
is somehow some-some liberation for us
no instead it makes things more
complicated more difficult for us and we
have to see it through all the way to
the end in a later passage he is going
to talk about human beings being prey to
their truth he says there exists an
obvious fact that seems utterly moral a
man is always prey to his truth once he
has admitted them he cannot free himself
from them one has to pay something a man
who has become conscious
the absurd is forever bound to it a man
devoid of hope and conscious of being so
has ceased to belong to the future that
is natural so he's telling us that once
the absurd has actually become you can't
say enter to your life it's become a
problem for you you can't say an entry
of your life because it's always been
there I think you've just become
cognizant of it once it's there
it would be a sort of if we want to use
a different author's term sort of bad
faith to pretend that it's not there and
to try to find some overarching meaning
that makes sense of everything instead
you have to acknowledge the absurd as it
is and not try to get rid of it a little
bit later he says it is natural that we
should strive to escape the universe of
which we are the Creator all of this has
significance only on account of this
paradox so on the one hand we encounter
the absurd we have to take stock of it
on the other hand we have a natural
repugnance to it we want to escape it
ignore it destroy it if we if we
possibly can answer as we can't and all
of that is is part of our our drives but
if we want to be consistent then we have
to stick with the absurd and not try to
make it go away
so like he says we are prey to our
truths once the absurd is gripped as we
are within the prey of that truth now
what does it mean to deal with the
absurd just a little bit before that he
actually says talking about carrying an
absurd logic to its conclusion he admits
that the struggle implies a total
absence of hope a continual rejection
and a continuous conscious
dissatisfaction those are parts of the
human response to the absurd and he says
that the absurd actually does have a
meaning only insofar as it is not agreed
to
right so it's not that the world becomes
totally meaningless we actually do have
a possibility
what is the absurd though we should
remind ourselves of
key feature of the absurd it's not that
the human being is perfectly fine and
you know no not a mess of contradictions
within and then the world is what is
absurd rather Camus says the absurd is a
triadic relation between the human being
and the world and the divorce between
the two and that it can happen in a lot
of different ways we don't need to go
into all of that but that's what he says
is actually absurd
now the seeming meaninglessness or
arbitrariness or disconnection of the
absurd might give some people the idea
that they don't need to follow through
on their reasoning about it shouldn't
they just say oh life is absurd do
whatever you want
you know maybe lose yourself at hedonism
maybe find yourself some project to
arbitrarily commit yourself to maybe
just wander around and in sort of a
mindless you know curious state looking
at this looking at that maybe do
something else maybe accumulate
thousands of copies look whose works all
of those could be responses kemon who
doesn't think that that's what taking
the absurd seriously really means
instead we should realize that we do in
fact have the possibility of introducing
meaning we just have to understand that
it is not going to stand the test of
time and it's not going to survive
unless you know we're very lucky beyond
our death and it doesn't extend beyond
our own agency but we have the choice to
follow through or not to follow through
on the reasoning that we we actually
possess so he tells us and this is a
really important passage this is where
he's beginning to discuss the absurd man
and ethics he says that there is but one
moral code the absurd man can accept the
one that is not separated from God the
one that is dictated but it so happens
he lives outside that guy
and then he goes on a little bit further
and he says the certainty of a God
giving a meaning to life far surpasses
and attractiveness the ability to behave
badly with impunity the choice would not
be hard to make but there is no choice
both of those options are closed off and
this is where the bitterness comes in
the absurd does not liberate it binds it
does not authorize all actions
everything is permitted does not mean
that nothing is forbidden the absurd
merely it confers an equivalence on the
consequences of those actions
it does not recommend crime for this
would be childish but it restores to
remorse its futility and then here's the
key point
likewise if all experiences are
indifferent that of Duty is as
legitimate as any other one can be
virtuous through a whim so if we want to
follow through on the absurd that is up
to us that is a possibility for human
beings and we can behave as decent human
beings without some sort of transcendent
grounding like you know God's love or
some sort of command or you know the
very nature of humanity itself or what
evolutionary biology teaches us all that
we can say that's that's all you know
smoke and mirrors but I can still choose
decency for myself
he's a term that you'll see in a lot of
caboose works so it doesn't find the
choice of life and our conduct is still
up to us and it would have to be guided
by what it is that we actually believe
if we want to remain consistent if we
have that inclination of being in
harmony with ourselves now you might say
well I don't have that that inclination
and Camus could say to you more power to
you buddy you go ahead and do what you
want to do I'm just telling you what if
you actually do want to be consequent to
yourself if you actually do want to be
coherent this is what would be required
but I'm not binding you to that if
anything only you can decide for
yourself whether that matters to you
so what we see here is that cow Moos
absurdism doesn't simply lead to a
universe totally devoid of meaningful
choices or requirements or actions those
stem from us and our engagement with
that world in the absurd
you